but it's 1969 that could not be better
for a joke
all right yes you set me up for success
honey
all right here we go my vision
for the stand by you concert special
was to really reflect the lgbtq
community
on the stage it was my honor it was my
privilege to stand there and to
represent an
entire community and i wanted to make
sure i
served it justice which is what we
demand
the ryman auditorium is literally the
nucleus
of country music and i just filled it
with [ __ ] drag queens
it has inspired all country artists from
all different generations and it is the
house of hee haw
since 1916
there's going to be a lot of those cheap
jokes but no cheap looks hanging
[Applause]
i wanted to open the stand by you
special with a very
miley fied monologue
we're known for our whiskey and no fur
jam and being too glam to give a damn it
was a little bit of everything that i do
we laugh we smile we make jokes we keep
it light-hearted but we also address
issues we address why we have filled up
the ryman auditorium
what's brought us all together why we're
here not only to celebrate
but demand changes so i thought that i
could give a little bit of everything it
could be fun it could be
showbiz but it could also be direct
talking to everyone at home
about what we ask of them after the
special and how they could get involved
i want to also talk to everybody
directly at home
i know a lot of us have been divided
we've been separated we've been isolated
we've been distanced
and so i thought it was really important
for those that could
come together and fill this place with
human beings and connections and
real vibes and energy but also to not
forget about everybody who's watching at
home and tuning in because it is just as
important for them
to be engaged to be paying attention not
only to the music
to about everything we're saying and
what we need for the lgbtq community to
continue to thrive blessings
i chose to do we belong by pat benitar
with brothers osborne because
sometimes you can't always judge a book
by its cover we have a lot more in
common than just
listening to our music or seeing us on
stage we really connected i consider
those dudes
friends of mine and now family they were
really there when i needed them and so i
thought it was
perfect for this song to really reflect
our relationship irl
honey i picked dancing queen for me
and maren morris to perform together i
love marin she's a real friend of mine
we've actually sang together before for
a dolly tribute so i knew that we could
do harmonies
i knew what she was gonna bring vocally
and i know that it's something very
different
from my approach to a song sometimes
when things are
different that's what makes them really
beautiful and makes them go together
it's called sweet and salty i chose to
close the standby you special
with freedom by george michael because
that's really what standby u
is all about it's about demanding
freedom for all americans
miss tennessee join me to celebrate
pride through the power of music
see you there are we rolling on that
because that's good
um i want that
[Music]
you